good morning believe nation today's
message is be present over to you Chris
Evans you said that it's there's a
search to be in the moment does that
only apply to acting
it's everything that reality looks and
feels and smells and sounds like but you
know it's not and and you're completely
in control of that unfolding and that's
the time where I really feel the most
present and I think that's part of my
addiction to acting because I struggle
to find that in life it's a bit harder
when there's no script and this is just
happening in a chaotic form but the hunt
for the moment you know the hunt to be
present that's the goal I mean acting is
like a temporary artificial substitute
that it's like a drug it's great my goal
in life is to find that you know to be
present like that in life it's hard I
think it's super easy to get distracted
as an entrepreneur I think entrepreneurs
get distracted all the time and prevents
you from accomplishing the big goals
that you want to accomplish I think it's
a couple reasons for it I think a lot of
entrepreneurs have a DD diagnosed or not
diagnosed we just tend to like to jump
around the do a whole bunch of different
things I think also part of the reason
is we don't have a manager we don't have
a boss you know when you have a boss is
telling you what to do is set guidelines
and objectives then you're gonna do it
otherwise you're gonna get in trouble
with your manager you might get fired
who's gonna fire you you know you don't
fire yourself and so you end up letting
yourself down you say you're gonna do
this and then as soon as it gets hard or
you lose interest in it you jump to
something else and as a result what a
lot of entrepreneurs do is they have all
these projects that are 10 20 30 40 50 %
done look at all the things that you
started and stopped and they're kind of
sitting there on the sidelines and
you've done nothing with it's super
common a lot of entrepreneurs do this
but you don't get the results you don't
get the fruits unless you take it to
100%
you're not gonna cash in on something
that's 50% done 20% done and as soon as
something gets hard or
as soon as we hit a roadblock a lot of
times what entrepreneurs do is they say
I'm not interested in that anymore
that's not what I want to do I'm not
passionate about that I'm gonna go and
do something else and just see if that's
your habit see how often you actually
follow through all the way to completion
that idea you had or did you start it
and when it got hard you stopped the
move to something else and so the two
things that I find really helped me is
one having having a mission having a
vision like what do I want to do what am
I here to do I want to help a billion
entrepreneurs I want to have a big
impact on this planet and my path is by
believing in entrepreneurs that's what I
want to do I wake up thinking about the
impact that I want to have today on the
planet and what that does is help get me
through a lot of the crap because being
an entrepreneur is not all roses there's
a lot of really bad days that a lot of
people don't talk about when I was
writing my book there were a lot of bad
days and what gets me through is I want
to write this book I wanted to inspire
lots of entrepreneurs I wanted to have
an impact and so having a clear mission
understanding the bigger picture
remembering your why what you're doing
here can help get you through that final
50% or maybe even just the final 10%
that's just really hard I need that
extra little kick the second thing that
really helps me too is having a schedule
so I know what I'm doing every single
day of the week I've booked it in one
day I'm working my YouTube channel one
day I'm working on Toronto dance salsa
then one day I'm doing meetings and so I
have it set up in my calendar that this
is what I'm working on today I've
allocated the amount of time that I need
to go off and have a big impact in that
area of my business or my life and so
those two things remembering the Y and
scheduling it in helps take those
projects that maybe I would dump at 50%
because I don't have anybody watching me
there's no manager holding me
accountable and allows you to follow
through and finish to 100% so I can get
the rewards that I'm after so the
question that today is I'm curious how
do you guys stay present how do you guys
stay focused how do you make sure the
projects that you say you're gonna
finish you actually follow through and
finish them leave it down the count's
below super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shot
- Kaitlyn gag Kaitlyn thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word really really really means a
lot to me and I hope you're enjoying the
read so thank you guys again for
watching
I believe in you hope you can t to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
when I'm playing football I appreciate
it
I'm nowhere else I'm in the present
there's probably the best part about
best part about my life is that to be in
the present you talk about how do you
enjoy your life how do you find balance
right it's to live in the present you
plead to live like a kid like why do
kids have so much fun because they just
care about what they're doing yeah and
if we thought about what we were doing
all the time you do that when you're on
the football field it's probably the
only place that I can really do that
when I really truly am my authentic self
I mean a lot of people see if my close
close friends do but when I'm on the
football field there's no it's just raw
I don't like to think too far ahead so
you haven't taught I don't like thinking
too far ahead people say it like goals
long-distance goals and [ __ ] that's too
much for me I already feel like I'm
living it and then I just carry on the
old I you know carry on day by day
already living the final goal the goal
of being the world champion I already
carry myself like I'm my world champ and
I already speak like I'm a world
champion and and that's it I just carry
on day by day so I'll take it as a
corpse a lot again like I said you were
awesome
ask me about the future I'll let you
I'll let you know a little bit closer I
mean as far all I can see right now is
the cold that's all I can see your
background is fairly well documented
that the things you went through which
have shaped you how much of that is
really behind you or how much do those
ghosts still haunt you the the
involvement in in you know issues that
got you imprisoned and tortured and you
know the drug use and so on I am a
myself and my circumstance I think that
like a Spanish philosopher uses to say
so Who am I I'm a sum of all the
experiences that I lived in my life that
said of course I don't look back because
if I look back at the I may become a
startle of salt so I try to live my life
here but it is the sum of difficult
moments good moments
well experiences that I had in my life
that brought me here in front of you of
this camera talking to you you don't
live your life in this capitalistic
sense
that accumulate knowledge has
accumulated money no no no no life is
about the present moment and you're here
you're here now and then you have an
idea we have something but that may be a
routine year of past but you don't know
so what I try to do is to live my life
as full as as intensely as I